great so i think jay probably needs no
introduction to everyone who's here to
uh listen about transformers um i think
all of us have kind of
started by trying to read the attention
is all you need paper and gotten
completely confused by this crazy
architecture diagram and then
immediately gone to jay's super
influential blog post called the
illustrator transformer where he really
nicely shows kind of conceptually how
these things work
and then there's a whole series of
beautiful blog posts ranging from pandas
to nunpai to bert gpg i mean the whole
works so
thank you jay for this amazing service
you've done to the community you've kind
of demystified transformers um which is
amazing and today um jay's going to talk
to us about a gentle visual introduction
to transformer models
so i'll add
yep great thing there and perfect
ryoka on audio
all good
amazing thank you so much that's a very
kind introduction uh happy to be here uh
speaking about uh transformers
there's a couple of examples on a
notebook this is a url to it but it's uh
you know just a very simple sort of sort
of notebook to go over
[Music]
to to give some let's say history
these are some some milestones from the
history of writing right so
first time sort of people put
drawings on tablets
and then people put language carved it
carved their laws of an entire let's say
society on on a column that's
law the second image uh below then
people started using paper
um and then we have something like the
the printing machine or the printing
press that sort of um
pushed the next let's say revolution and
books became cheaper to get and
knowledge and literacy became uh easier
so once you need a book you don't need
to go and copy it with with your hand
that sort of changed the world then i do
have a sense looking back at the history
that nlp
via sort of what machine learning is is
enabling us to do that we could be at a
at a historical sort of turning point
where exactly are we did it happen the
last uh two or three years or is it
gonna happen in the next few years um
it's very hard to tell if you're not
sort of looking back to history but i'm
extremely fascinated
by these sort of language models and
i'll tell you a little bit why
so yeah it's a brief
bit about myself i i've been blogging
about machine learning and
transformers
uh
machine learning for maybe five six
years transformers since uh i wanted to
understand the paper and this is sort of
a map that i used to for me to
understand the paper and turned out to
be
useful to to other people
as well the blog has gotten about four
million page views just because
the the topic became super interesting
to to to people and then i wrote about
other types of transformers as well as
nlp technology so embeddings were to
back gpt3 bert and i do some some videos
on on youtube as well to sort of explain
some of these
um
i do work at cohere
as sort of
thomas mentioned we work on large
language models we offer sort of large
representational language models kind of
like birth and large generation language
models kind of like gpt so these are
massive language models via api for
people to experiment with and and
deploy in an industry so this is the url
and
we're hiring at the moment
one thing to allude to uh that thomas
mentioned is that transformers has taken
nlp uh by storm uh but not only nlp but
also like computer vision and it's like
going out of out of nlp this is the the
super glue
and you can see the transformer and
transformer based models uh have have
dominated the leaderboards
um if you go and search on google so
i have bringed up this example for
people who sort of want to understand a
little bit more of the current
applications so if you go on and to
search on on google
and you type some some words and you get
some recommendations your keyboard would
give you some recommendations but also
the search engine would give you some
some recommendations so let's say you
search for siri technology you get this
page
and then when you click on it sometimes
you get these highlighted sort of notes
i asked people which step in this
process used a language model
and in an audience like this i think you
would
realize that this is maybe a trick
question
and it's in all of them uh a language
model was used so
um
auto complete and sort of uh next word
uh can be used
via let's say language models
this
summarization
and highlighting uh these are all sort
of language model
tasks but there's even one that is more
important which is
where sort of google got you the results
so to give some sort of uh examples yes
we some of these tasks are let's say
autocomplete text summarization question
answering semantic search
and if you use gmail you have some of
these um
suggested responses that's response
selection that's also another thing that
language models are are heavily used for
so we're not talking about specific just
research um or you know interesting
ideas these are heavily in application
right now just even
less than less than a year since like
one of these papers is written it goes
into into industry um really quickly
so this is sort of across the board
google translate search uh all the
speech detection
um and then using it in in in search as
well uh so like a year i think after the
birth paper was out
the google search team said that it
implementing let's say semantic search
using a model like bert represented the
biggest leap forward in the past five
years and one of the biggest leaps
forward in the history of search
uh gpt-3 took the world by storm so many
interesting applications there
i think most of the team here has looked
at it so
to
think about transformer language models
uh for a second let's look at uh one of
the developments that that
have changed the game
that it
broke down this training process into
two steps one is pre-training where a
model is trained on a lot of data
and then you fine-tune it you train it
further for for a specific
use case
so if you want to create let's say a new
semantic or
[Music]
sentiment analysis let's say classifier
you don't have to train a model from
scratch uh you can train a model that
already understands english or
multilingual or whatever language that
you're so these are one of the this is
one of the
uh developments sort of that that made
these these models
revolutionary
the training process of a language model
and i'm here speaking about a
what's typically called a language model
which is an auto-regressive language
model kind of like gpt it's trained on a
very basic task which is you give it
let's say three tokens or three words
and you hold off what the correct
correct word is so a robot must obey
but you don't tell it to be just give it
to three tokens
or three words it will make a prediction
the model is not trained so it will
output a random output
we know what the actual output that we
were expecting is
we calculate the error we update the
model
and then we do this for a lot of uh
tokens 300 billion in in gpt 3's case
and then once you've
pre-trained it you can deploy it or
fine-tune it or prompt engineer it for
for these other use cases
to tackle the the architecture a little
bit um i've
always felt that it's easier to look at
it as just one black box and the initial
transformer uh was about um
translation so you give it a sentence
and in french it outputs a sentence in
english so
you can visualize it kind of like this
and then if you're to look under the
hood it has two major components an
encoder and a decoder
and these encoder and decoder are made
up of blocks uh six blocks in the
encoder and six in the decoder that's
the initial sort of transformer paper
um
and then these are the main
architectural ideas um i think that are
good to establish first before thinking
about different types of transformers
so the initial transformer was an
encoder decoder model so that works
really well for say
things like
machine translation uh but also there
are still models that are you know
continuing to to tackle this this
structure so it's still very useful uh
on certain uh use cases so t5 t0 that
was sort of recently uh developed as
well is is this encoder decoder
and i think mina google ai's large
chat bot is is one of these encoder
decoder models
on the other hand you have models that
are trained completely using decoders
uh so these are the your your gpt models
uh they're just like the traditional
autoregressive
models and then you have births like
models
structured using only the encoder sort
of stack
and that is tends to be called masked
language modeling so you have language
models mask language models and you have
like encoder decoder
transformers so this is uh to to orient
yourself and all of these are widely in
use uh a lot of them are have specific
tasks that they do better in uh than the
others
uh our talk will focus um on the
transformer language model
so this is going to be
the type of model that we focus on
another idea
is how many layers can you sort of stack
how many blocks can you can you stack
and bert's large has about 24.
gt2 large has about 36
so these are
another aspect let's say of transformers
is
so you can talk about how large the the
neural networks inside are but also how
many blocks that you use stack to get
your model
so let's talk about language models
i've found that there's a
two really good examples to to break
down the components of a transformer
layer so let's think about a model that
has let's say only one one layer
if you give the model an example of
this input which is the shawshank
and then
this model is trained so it has
hopefully seen uh words kind of like
this or phrases kind of like this before
um
you would be able to think that it is
able to guess what the next word is and
this is a a reference to
the film the shawshank redemption
and i i tried this using the distilled
gpt2
example and when you pass it the
shawshank it gives you this completion
so it's able to actually know what word
i was expecting
after
shawshank
and this really explains to you one of
the two major components of a
transformer block which is the feed
forward neural network so in the
training when the model was trained on
vast amounts of data
previously it is able to calculate these
probabilities of words appearing after
the current context that you have
so two words here what would the third
be and this is a very similar so this is
not new as a technology in transformers
it's very similar to previous uh
language models and then
three grams and engrams uh that were
calculated using just counting how many
times
this word has appeared before sort of or
after this context and creating a
probability uh
distribution or score via that so this
is one of the two major components the
feed forward neural network and this is
an example where it shines i was able to
sort of
remember
or have a calculation of what the next
word would be just judging on what the
model has seen before
this is a paper from 2003 about these
models and how they they were there sort
of
previously and
transformers build on on top of this
now the second component is a little bit
more complex and this is a great example
to uh illustrate it so when you say the
chicken did not cross the road because
it and you want the model to complete
what the next word would be
now the model cannot only calculate you
know what words usually appear after the
word it
that would not
produce a really good model it will not
be able to fit its data set really well
and before it sort of does that
it needs to resolve what does it refer
to here does it refer to the chicken
or does it refer to the road
so that ambiguity is is there and we can
throw this as at a small gpt uh example
and we can see if we say the chicken
didn't cross the road because it was
covered in grass so that's probably the
road right
uh he thought the sun wasn't so bad then
then now i don't know maybe it was maybe
the chicken was covered in grass and
the sun was not so bad so
this is sort of a good example of this
other component of a transformer block
which is self-attention
what self-attention does is that when
the model is processing this token
self-attention associates it either with
the chicken or with the road or with a
mixture of both and really that it's a
mixture of of the entire
sentence
so that is one of the major things that
transformers brought
i guess to nlt in addition to
um
being
easier and better to run in parallel uh
as compared to rnns which were
used heavily before sort of transformers
took over so these are the two
components self-attention which
uh you know whenever you're processing a
token it bakes the in its understanding
or representation of that token uh
relevant information from other
parts of the input
and then feed forward which is
neural network which is
builds on top of that
the idea of tokenization is another
important one
so the example that i showed you here
was a little bit simplified when i
actually throw the shawshank at the
tokenizer of gpt2 is what i'm using here
it would break it down kind of like this
so these two words would be four tokens
and then a through the tokenizer that
would be translated into token ids
and these token ids will be the ones
that are uh hitting the model and then
the model outputs something that we can
translate into a word using the token
again and so if you're to to work with
with birth or gft models these are the
two let's say components pieces of code
and that that you'll have to deal with
the tokenizer which translates between
our words and let's say token ids and
the actual model which has never seen
any words has only seen token ids
so i'll leave you to be able to
go through the uh
notebook um
and this is sort of a an interesting uh
idea that i thought uh so gt3 this was
one of the let's say outputs of gt3
saying to be clear i'm not a person i'm
not self-aware i'm not conscious
i can't feel pain
i don't enjoy anything i am cold
calculating machine designed to simulate
a human response
so
this and other sort of interesting
generations from from massive language
models are very interesting if you can
think of them as
you know these were outputted by a
machine now
definitely should be suspicious uh until
you see sort of what the prompt was
but it's still
interesting
but what's more interesting is that the
model has never actually seen language
it has only seen word like token ids
kind of like this so when the model says
this
actually this is what its output is it
has never touched or seen
uh words but it just is able to model
sequences let's say of numbers and then
embeddings
embeddings is the next idea here which
is
breathing uh meaning into numbers into
these token ids
and so when you download let's say the
gpt model you would get with it a table
of uh let's say vocabulary size and
embedding for each
word that the model knows or each token
in the model's vocabulary
this is how you can look at it i don't
know if this is up to date with the
latest uh versions but
uh it was when i was sort of looking at
it so and you can just pass it let's say
the token id so there's a token id of
the word that and you can if you're like
me and just you're curious and you want
to look at these numbers do they make
sense they look like this
so
we have our words uh they're converted
into tokens through embedding they're
converted into vectors kind of like the
numbers that that we saw previously and
these are really the input into the
transformer block uh and if the input is
let's say four tokens you'd have these
four tracks going through the
transformer block and
an output at each one
and then however many blocks that you
have you can sort of each block works on
the output of the of the previous one
and these are called in states
when you're doing
text generation uh the one that you you
predict uh the next token using this
final one so if we're predicting let's
say the word uh redemption it would the
model would be working off of this final
hidden state of the final token
okay so
how do we turn computation into into
language how do we project the output
into into language and it looks kind of
like this so where this is the last
hidden state
of the last token so the model has
processed it done a lot of crunching and
then it outputs this this one vector
the let's say language model head would
project that so it would give a score to
each word in its vocabulary each token
in its vocabulary and we just pick the
highest one or we can that's one type of
output selection there are other
decoding strategies is is the word for
this but
say you just pick the highest one that
would be the word redemption
um
[Music]
so now you scale it and that's how you
sort of have these massive
language models they
process all of the all of these tokens
and then in the end they give you an
output and you feed that auto
aggressively so this token that comes
out is fed back into the model and
that's how the model continues to
produce token after token hey jay i have
a question um about scaling so
what do you mean by this is this uh
scaling like the architecture or do are
there other things we should consider
when we talk about scaling transformers
yes exactly so i'm talking about how do
you go from let's say gpt2 to gpt3 uh so
you have larger models larger uh
training sets
um
and then like even you you tr you
layer a higher let's say number of
layers more more transformer blocks
great and then the kind of follow-up
question would be um so at cohere i
think you mentioned you you you guys are
also training large language models
yourself yes and so i'm kind of
wondering like what kind of
considerations go into curating the data
sets um when you're when you're doing
this because we know that gbt3 for
example has a wide set of kind of known
biases and can lead to some kind of
generations that may be a sort of
harmful or offensive and so on i'm just
kind of curious how you guys think about
this
yes yes absolutely so there's the the
team works on uh filtering the the data
sets for for toxicity i think there's
there's a paper also uh there that i can
i can share uh after uh with the team so
exactly that that filtering off of the
data set uh is a very important
component that leads to models uh
hopefully that that can produce better
generations
awesome thank you
amazing thank you so much
ah so was that into your talk
that is the end of my talk great cool
great so we have a few more questions um
on the forums so this one is is more of
a um it's a general question
put it here in the chat so
do you see a future in symbolic learning
rather than probabilistic approaches
and i think this is kind of like you
know the the big topic on twitter
between barry marcus and
um you know other people who are like
connectionists and i'm curious to see
what your thoughts are true yeah i don't
have sort of much of a
an opinion i think we can probably use a
little bit of both the probabilistic has
really proven itself so i don't think
you can go without the probabilistic but
can you infuse it with a little bit more
rules like that's what we see in
chatbots so to speak you can use some of
the probabilistic but you have to sort
of encode
some of these some of your rules uh to
to actually have something that you can
let's say ship out to your customers now
yeah i think a kind of very related
question here is whether like
transformers or you know deep neural
networks in general can do true
extrapolation um and you know whether
we're just doing interpolation on some
sort of you know manifold in a lower
dimension and i think this is generally
what the symbolists are always you know
wanting us to you know pay attention to
sure true and there's there's some work
on
on causal sort of inference uh that's
been sort of dripping more and more in
into nlp and that sort of maybe goes
beyond uh
just let's say correlation into maybe
encoding some of the of the causation
cool so another question
we have here is um
so you know your blog as i mentioned at
the start has kind of helped everyone
visually understand what's going on
under the hood and sort of what concept
or architecture is like next on your on
your list
yeah so a lot of what i focus on
especially sort of in my my work with
cohere is how do we
get the best results from these models
in the real world and how do we apply
them to to real world problems so
um i've been thinking about things like
you know what are the best ways to
explain and think about things like
prompt engineering
and you know what's the best way to sort
of you know fine-tune
a model what should the data set sort of
uh look like so a lot of it i've been
sort of thinking about the applied side
for a while now and that sort of
gives me some
exposure into things like
or areas that are interesting both on
generation but also on the embedding
site kind of like dense retrieval and
semantic search um and these are sort of
you know very interesting uh
applications of models both of the bert
and the gpt types
awesome
i think we have another question here
it's a bit of a long one uh we'll see if
i can just read it out it doesn't quite
fit so
um it says
let's see so
for t5 um there's been around three
approaches that have been used to
fine-tune pre-trained models for all
downstream tasks so this is kind of like
where you fine-tune all of the layers or
you just freeze some layers or you know
do gradual unfreezing
and the question is that for models like
bert
which are more these encoder-based
models um
which of these approaches do you think
is best you know kind of using freezing
or just just fine-tuning the whole thing
yeah so it's a trade-off
it's really a trade-off so you can you
can get some value without fine-tuning
you you can fit some classifiers on top
of the frozen model to begin with you
can freeze some layers and uh train
let's say the final layers and you can
fine-tune the entire thing um but the
more
like fine-tuning that you do the more
training that you do that will take more
time it will might need a little bit
more data
there isn't a one-size-fits-all
unfortunately in machine learning most
of the answers are always
you know depends on the case
exactly and i think this is kind of very
closely related to this follow-up
question which is
sort of how do we know how much we
should fine-tune a pre-trained model so
are there some like general like
heuristics or
strategies that you sort of think about
when you're doing fine tuning
so fine tuning is a different
is a different beast so it's a word that
can use different things
it depends on the complexity of the task
that you want the model to accomplish so
if the model has been
has come across your task
in
its training set for example then you
don't need a lot of fine-tuning because
if you let's say get data from the web
and you train the model to do language
modeling on it it would see things like
paragraph and then in summary and then a
summary summary under it so it wouldn't
need a lot of data to
grasp the concept of let's say
summarization because it was already
sort of kind of trained on it but if you
have something where
uh the the relationship between the
input that you want and the output is is
is difficult uh then you will need a bit
more sort of data and it's it's similar
to however you want to fit
features and labels in a general machine
learning uh algorithm if the
relationship is easy if it's sort of the
model is able to do it with less data if
it's complex
then that's
you know you might need infinite data
for it
exactly and i think this is also perhaps
why everyone has got so excited about
models like gt3 because they kind of
showed like in tom's talk he mentioned
this kind of curve where you can see you
know the performance as a function of
number of examples and in the few short
case where you only need 10 examples and
you're still you know
almost you know several tens of points
better than everything else this is
quite impressive and maybe just one last
question for you because occur here i
guess you're doing few shot learning
is did you see this technique of like
prompt engineering or future learning
becoming kind of as commonplace in
industry
um as you know the current paradigm we
use of you know collecting several
thousand examples and you know training
our classifiers
yeah so it is and it depends on on the
use case and it's really better for some
use cases uh rather than that than
others uh you can have a lot of let's
say cases where you don't have that data
or it's very difficult but that
relationship is somehow encoded through
uh examples that the model has seen
before so it's
for people without a lot of data sets uh
fusha learning is one thing to to to
experiment with it is convenient
uh but it has that it's
against empirical and experimental uh
sort of in nature uh
but if you have only five or ten
uh or fifty examples uh it's it's worth
experimenting with it if it's too
expensive for you to actually get enough
of a data set to train a full model
totally so
that's i think all the questions we have
from the community right now and uh
thank you once again for this beautiful
talk and for taking part in this event i
think everyone really enjoys
um seeing your your amazing slides and
images
amazing thank you so much i appreciate
it i love all your work happy to be here
thank you so much